let's say New Orleans if you're if
you're walking down the street of New
Orleans what do they say to you and then
I want to ask you what would they say to
you if you're walking down the streets
of Carolina or Atlanta in New Orleans
it's simple it's just who that it's
that's it that's an easy easy
across the street down the sidewalk it's
kind of like that fraternity but they
don't ask you specifics about the team
it's more of just that Saints greedy
that's the Saints greeting in a more
intimate setting it might be hey you
know how are we going to be this year
it's a it's a it's a unique fan base
because when you really look at all the
SEC football that exists in Alabama
Mississippi even into Florida there's
one NFL team and so it's it's Alabama
its Mississippi it's the panhandle of
Florida that's all
Saints country and that's where our
season ticket holders come from as well
so they're very passionate well having
the proximity to LSU but but still
having an SEC feel to your fan base is
kind of remarkable because usually in
the south their professional teams are
their college - absolutely absolutely
Mississippi Mississippi State Auburn
Alabama LSU all of it within a I would
say four-hour drive from from where
we're at you watch a lot of college
football we get the second half's when
we get to the hotel it's on in the
training room we catch the end of games
our players our younger players
especially our vested in those scores
can you get anything from like if you
watch the shaun watson against alabama
yeah could you come away from the gang
oh yeah you could absolutely there's
something special about them right I
mean I just met him two minutes ago and
when you watch the game it's always
interesting to hear him talk afterwards
and I think he he appears to have all
those things that we're looking for
I was talking to Drew Brees yesterday
and I said to him you know I know he
wants to play a couple more years I
don't know how long he wants to play but
he still loves work
he still loves practice and I think
that's the first thing that leaves you
is that enthusiasm to prepare and get
better yeah
and he's one of those competitive people
I've ever met and that's saying a lot
artist yeah but Brees is competitive we
read him his draft analysis tool as last
year we got we just had the negatives
and we had him read what they said about
him coming out of college he said can I
have this he wanted the piece of paper
that it was on he said I'm going to use
this as motivation was he fuming holy
Dan at it was after last year of the
Super Bowl we read it it was fun hijinks
on the air and they kind of go - you got
a copy that I want to bring it home up
put up and wear it let's wait what does
it imagine no I mean that's but yeah job
easier absolutely what it does it make
your job tougher that you eventually
have to draft his replacement don't you
well I think being in the drafter on
free agency and yet that transaction may
take place not in the same year that
he's being replaced or we pay close
attention to hey what are what are the
signs and I don't see any we don't see
any we just finished reading our team
and his preparation his attention to
detail is amazing but his movement
skills you know these guys are so much
further along in regards to the rest of
the recovery their nutrition yeah I mean
it wasn't long ago where it was a fresca
and a marvel at halftime like that
wasn't that long ago and I just think
that where we've come from a training
standpoint is extended in your scene
guys you know the Mannings and the
Bradys and the breeders seeing these
guys play longer because of a much more
different training regimen what did you
think of Brady coming out of college do
remember and I knew we share the same
agent and so this was at a time when
there wasn't a lot of information about
the combine and so Donny would have me
occasionally call a prospect that he had
and kind of filament as to this is what
to expect you know you're going to be in
a dome your hands are going to be sweaty
the balls are going to be kind
they're not going to be the broken-in
Pat balls you're used to throwing so get
six new balls out try to throw in this
condition of 68 degrees just little
things that prep a guy for the combine
and I can recall conversations with him
leading up to the draft and I was at the
Giants I had a high grade on a Mirnyi of
course he will tell you this my only
problem is the Scout to my left whitey
who was there later in his career and
whitey was the Scout that he was there
still bless the marriage but you know
his reports would be and my biggest fear
happened when it came to me and I went
through my grade and why I saw him as
this white he agreed with me and it was
over
when whitey agreed with me I had no
chance of like pushing this would you
with a giant subtracted him yeah I think
I think our final grade probably was in
the fourth round and one of the things
that happens in the draft all the time
is if you're in the fifth round
you're probably drafting a player you've
got graded in the third round because
everyone else isn't seeing it exactly as
you see it so at some point it gets off
two rounds and then when you're in round
four there's a two that's still sitting
there on your board when you're in six
there's a four or maybe a three on your
board so it would be very rare to have a
fifth round great on a player and draft
him in the fifth round by the time you
get to that round because you're
probably going to have a few players
graded higher that happened with with
Romo in Dallas you know we had a fifth
round grade we began discussing drafting
him and then all the way into the
seventh round there was a higher graded
player when we signed him as a free
agent we're talking to Drew Brees there
I drew briefs as coach they should say
he's on my mind Sean Payton the Saints
head coach but also I you know I don't
know like the Packers did this with
Aaron Rodgers
you know the the awkward timing of we
got to draft somebody or the Broncos
with tommy maddox in John Elway like it
can be
delicate but yeah I think the one thing
about Drew is I know this about him is
regardless of who we select and we've
selected Garrett Grayson a couple years
ago in the third round I think it's it's
seen that wait a minute it's a first
round or second round pick and the other
part of that that's difficult sometimes
when you're in his position is you're
looking at it like man I want you know
another player that can help me right
now so I think the organization looks at
it closely as to hey now and then
long-term and so it's the more it's a
bigger topic when it's a first-round
selection with a current player and Rex
the quarterback but the value change so
much for Aaron we have to take them I
think that it's really happened a
hundred times in sport yeah you know
it's just it's the it's the cycle I also
wanted to ask you about one of the gutsy
calls in Super Bowl history where you
come out second half and you have the
onside kick when do you think about the
onside kick the the beginning process
was the bye week it was all about
stealing a possession from Peyton they
were playing well offensively and you
know let's say we were 11 or 12
possessions a game they were scoring at
a high rate
Parcells who was at that time with Miami
talked about that very same moment in
the NFC Championship game when the
Giants faked a pun against the 49ers a
high scoring team trying to change you
know all of a sudden a 12 possession
game for somebody in a 10 you know
creating a turnover but there wasn't a
good look from a punt standpoint we kind
of had gone down that path and and then
we started looking at the the onside
kick and there were some conviction the
concern I had was the kicker thomas
moore said was a rookie and the mistake
I made at halftime
telling him we were going to start the
second half with that at the beginning
at halftime because half times 35
minutes and so
oh he like sat in his locker for 39
eating a turkey croissant like just
thinking instead of telling him as we
were going out which would have been
better but it was gutsy if you don't get
that do you wonder if you win the
Superbowl out but think about this for a
second that'd be the downside if it's
recovered is the 38 yard line the 40
yard line 40 to 40 in to pass plays
that's where Manning's at yeah and that
game was low scoring in the first half
we had enough time we knew we were going
to start the second half with it and we
had enough time to script the first
eight plays of the second half and go
through the first eight plays and so you
know going through that offensively it's
left hash and we're on their side of the
50 and then I want you to get in the
moment and here's here are the plays and
we scored on play six exactly as the
script unfolded now that rarely happens
but the the downside would be just a
little shorter field for an offense
that's already I think you know moving
it a what you got to play this up a
little more Sean if we're going to
create this legacy here that it's one of
the most I did here here it is the
mistake really is going in it to have
telling the officials we're going to
kick from left to right because that's
the way the wind was blowing you follow
we had the choice because we had the
width ball in the first half so they
asked you before you win which way do
you want to kick it left to right with
the win we make the decision about the
onside kick and coming out onto the
field I'm talking to Salomon Wilcox in
an interview and I see the officials
teeing the ball up and I realized the
onside kick is going to be on the Colts
bench and immediately I sprint out to
the crew and I said I want to go right
to left right to left because let's face
it that was like a scrum right I mean
you know Alabama's last year's on site
Yahoo is magnificent it was thought it
was clear
ours was a 50/50 ball and I think it
helped it
on our sideline I'll give you a time to
give a little plug here what you're
doing with the zebra technologies you
brought did you write well and gifts
here it's a niches this is our rent this
is our league we got shoulder pads here
so for the last three years the company
zebra who they do all our barcodes they
do everything 95% of all of our fortune
500 companies work with this company so
where you see a scan your your morning
coffee your groceries your ski lift
ticket your air they're in it that's
them they track they track things and
they put a small chip every one of our
players has one of these in the NFL and
I think when we see these next-gen stats
I don't think our fans realize where
Tyree kills 23 mile an hour time comes
from but it's it's from these two chips
and every field in our league is marked
just like an invisible fence and so when
you enter that field attracts data and
it's pretty interesting it's a pretty
interesting concept relative to us as
coaches because I want this after
practice the average receiver travels
six miles of practice and Brandon Cook
travels Brandon cooks traveled 8.2 for
the first week he was here and that's a
soft tissue injury waiting to happen but
from a fan standpoint you get a chance
to to to hear terms like miles per hour
we're going to be able to chart kicks
through the uprights where they're go
we're going to know if a ball crosses
the goal line we can do that today yeah
alright whether a guy steps out of
bounds these chips the chips in the ball
right now Thursday Night Football the
chips been in the ball and it can
measure spin it's pretty smart
considering our investment you know how
fast how long how many throws someone
want to try these on but Paul T you want
to put them on yeah we're going to track
Paulie
well you how would you give pulling a
pep talk though that's I'd like one L
coach well by the way this is zebra
technology the official on-field player
tracking provider the NFL
pump up your form going like a Friday
night like oh they're good real quickly
I will so this is just this carpet here
Paul is his it has to be the field we
need a field that mark and so it is
marked and Pauly it you don't get many
chances to play football in the state of
Texas gone I don't know where you're
from where you're from is outside
Chicago south side of Chicago well
you're not from Texas that's a long way
from Kansas Dorothy
just get your ass ready to go here just
run this way I don't need to see you
yeah you're not down belches yeah down I
like your effort I like your attitude
there you go and so all the wild poly
doing is we're recording we're tracking
this we're tracking it and we're
gathering this information we're getting
your heart rate as well was a great
surgery go the track though and the data
probably will be very very average and
yes and it'll be real it will blow
everything all right no talent all right
next gen stuff that's what we're getting
all ready
it's zebra Technologies the official
unfilled player tracking provider of the
NFL Shaun straight see you thank you for
stopping by we appreciate it being a
little short there
Kristin Thompson will join us coming up
in a little bit by the way Coach's
Corner Continental Tire Coaches Corner
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive or what you
drive Continental designs tires for what
you do for more info visit Continental
Tire comm Continental Tire for what you
do
Thank You coach we're back after this on
the Dan Patrick show the Dan Patrick
show weekday morning on audience
[Music]